hey 42 here we all love video game my
generation grew up to witness its birth
and we enjoyed legendary classics such
as Super Mario World
Zelda Final Fantasy Crash Bandicoot and
so many of us but beyond the styles of
trips of pixels and sprites these games
had a very special quality that modern
games don't quite have and it was quite
simple really
you paid Watson you own the game you
waltz into your local video game store
handed over a small wad of cash and you
received a cartridge with your new game
on it that was your property for life
Nintendo would never knock on your door
and ask you to pay a fiver for a new
colored tie for your Donkey Kong or
retailer to be able to play as Luigi
instead of Mario these things were just
included in the base game by default
with over 2.3 billion gamers worldwide
the video game industry has grown into
the world's largest entertainment
industry were significantly more than
film and music in fact with a forecasted
revenue of two hundred and thirty
billion dollars per year in the US by
2022 the video game industry is set to
become the world's largest industry full
stop perhaps bigger than food and oil
but during this period of tremendous
growth something unsettling has happened
to the video game industry the young
generation today have unquestionably
better games than my peers 20 odd years
ago the complexity of the worlds and
interactions impressive character AI
incredible depth of storytelling which
often Trump's most modern movies
breathtaking visuals under competitive
scene that is soon going to overtake
traditional sports in viewership numbers
those gamers should be thankful for the
pieces of art crafted from pixels that
we have to play with today and the
nostalgic games of the 80s and 90s are
just that nostalgia they belong in the
past but with this growing industry an
unsavory trend has emerged that anyone
who has purchased a video game in the
past five years will have undoubtedly
noticed every game release is full of
upsells once you fork out 40-plus pounds
to buy the game itself
you're then affronted with endless DLCs
and in game stores containing endless
cosmetic items and sometimes god forbid
pay to win items but what may shock you
is too complex casino psychology that
large game companies routinely abuse to
get you addicted to the games you play
and addicted to spending money on these
unscrupulous techniques are most
obviously on display in free-to-play
games sometimes referred to as freemium
games because they're free to download
and play but you soon find out that you
have to hand over cash to unlock most of
the characters use certain weapons or
items or progress past a certain point
in the game what may surprise you is
that many of the companies that
developed freemium games have been known
to hire the world's best psychologists
and neuroscientists to come up with ways
to make their games more addictive and
to trick children into spending more of
their parents money one of the simplest
ways game companies increase spending is
by dissociating money from reality
notice how games very rarely call our
in-game currency pounds or dollars they
usually invent a name for it such as
gold various gems vie books influence
credit warps shards the list goes on and
on there is a powerful and very
intentional psychological trick going on
here repeated studies have found that
the less we think of money as a tangible
object the more of it we recklessly
spend it has been proven that people are
willing to spend up to eighty three
percent more when paying for items via a
credit or debit card than cash the less
it feels like we are spending actual
money that we could hold in our hands
than the less significant we place on
handing it over this is exactly why
casinos use poker chips and it's why
games use virtual currencies another
psychological trick the gaming companies
of copied directly from the casino floor
is something called a progress gate this
is a point where the fun stops and you
have to pay money to continue playing
and continue having fun
slot machines utilize what's known as a
hard progress gate you have to deposit
more money into the machine to continue
playing . and unless you do your game
stops right there modern video games
instead use what's called a soft
progress gate this means you will get to
a certain point where you have to take a
break for an hour or two before you can
play again or a particularly boring part
of the game takes ages for you to
complete unless you hand over a bit of
cash and you can complete it right away
soft progress gates can be implemented
into games in a myriad of different ways
for example you may have to wait two
hours for your virtual farm to grow more
carrots before you can log on again to
harvest them but amazingly if you pay
just three dollars they will grow
instantly or it could be unlocking a new
champion on that popular mobile you like
to play you could technically play for
hundreds of hours to unlock that
champion for free but if you pony up a
tenner you can unlock it right away this
is a soft progress gate and soft
progress gates tie in perfectly with
another casino like mechanic which seems
like a frustrating staple in every game
on the market right now loot boxes if
you don't know a loot box is when you
play for hours to unlock a box full of
random rewards such as new costumes or
items for your character but 99% of the
time you can pay real money for virtual
currency which you can then use to buy
loot boxes instantly in any quantity you
desire without having to dedicate
hundreds of hours into grinding and
button mashing zombies into oblivion to
unlock just one loot box the links
between gambling and loot boxes are
obvious in fact it would be difficult to
argue that League boxes are not
straight-up gambling
after all you aren't straight up paying
for item X while Zed you are paying for
a random chance to get XY or Z and most
of the time you get worthless crap
instead the psychologists who work on
these systems often add a novel layer of
trickery in the form of entrapment a
well designed game monetization system
won't present you of any soft progress
gates or opportunities to purchase loot
boxes until you've played the game for a
few hours and you are and trapped within
it meaning you are already addicted to
the gameplay if you are presented with
an in-game shop the moment you load up a
game that you've never played before you
would naturally be put off but if you
have already enjoyed that game for
several hours and you are well on your
way to becoming addicted to the gameplay
then statistically you are significantly
more likely to want to pony up some cast
you progress further or unlock more loot
and when you do get hit with that first
opportunity to pay to upgrade your
experience it will likely come wrapped
up in another neat psychological trick
in the form of an offer or bundle by
bundling items together and offering a
slight discount players are likely to
spend more than they otherwise would if
they were to buy the items individually
this is an age-old sales trick it's not
unique to video games literally every
online retail store offers bundles of
some sort when was the last time you
purchased a TV online and it didn't try
to upsell you a bundle that includes a
fancy surge protected power bar an
overpriced gold-plated HDMI cable and
perhaps a sound bar that will blow your
nipples off the consumer probably didn't
want any of those additional items in
the first place but because they save
20-pound by going for it all together in
a bundle it seemed like a great deal at
the time despite the fact that they've
now spent an extra four hundred pounds
in addition to the television which they
otherwise wouldn't have loot boxes
bundles special offers and sales upon
actually sales are all pervasive
throughout the gaming industry it has
gotten to the point where all modern
video games mimic casino psychology
players becoming
to the game and always want just one
more go just one more loot box they
suffer from the gamblers fallacy players
falsely feel like by spending more they
are increasing their odds of unlocking
that specific golden item that they
desire but in reality there are two
remain the same no matter how much they
spent and if they don't get that item
after spending a large amount of money
they will often keep spending until they
do it's not the players fault this is
exactly how modern games have been
designed but by far the worst offenders
in the entire industry are mobile game
publishers the mobile gaming industry is
currently worth around 150 billion
dollars the mobile gaming crowd is a
completely different demographic to your
more serious PC in console gamers
demographically PC and console gamers
are overwhelmingly male whereas mobile
gamers are mostly female but what's
important is that mobile gamers are far
less likely or happy to pay outright for
the game consumers are used to paying to
download and play almost all triple-a PC
and console games upfront although that
trend is starting to shift now as more
free-to-play titles are beginning to
emerge in contrast mobile gamers
severely dislike paying upfront for a
game and the vast majority will never do
so even if they want to play it as a
result the industry has had to adapt to
turn a profit in truth the techniques
that mobile game publishers employ
aren't entirely their fault they have
been forced into adopting these revenue
models to maintain a healthy business in
2012 80% of AppStore games were free
today that has risen to over 90% but the
scariest figure is that a whopping 95
percent of revenue from all mobile games
comes from in-app purchases alone these
so-called freemium mobile games use all
the same casino style psychology as
their console counterparts and often a
sickening amount more of it but the
statistics about who is spending all the
money may surprise you only 0.15 percent
of mobile
gamer's are responsible for fifty to
seventy percent of all revenues from
in-app purchases these few consumers who
repeatedly spend hundreds or even
thousands on in-app purchases are
lovingly referred to by the industry as
Wales game developers pray or need wales
to consistently milk them of their cash
on a daily basis Wales usually don't
realize how much they're spending on
pixels because they're spending consists
of microtransactions in-app purchases
are designed to be very low cost usually
only a few pounds or even pence but when
a whale is making lots of those
transactions everyday over a period of
months it can add up to thousands of
pounds it's really difficult for
consumers to total up all of their in
app purchases and work out what they've
actually spent and people rarely do game
companies rely on the spending going
under the radar all these shady tricks
and techniques call into question the
ethics of such business models
especially when a large portion of the
customers are under 18 years old you
could argue that if people want to waste
their money on pixels it's their own
prerogative and their own problem but
it's difficult to use that reasoning
when teenagers are using their parents
credit cards to spend hundreds on loot
boxes and in-app purchases sometimes
without their parents even realising
until it's too late
there was a recent story about an 11
year old in the UK who racked up six
thousand pounds on his dad's credit card
over a few days of play because he was
signed into his father's Apple account
on his iPad the child didn't even
realize he was spending real money when
he was buying in-game credits and slowly
the government's are beginning to cotton
onto this issue a recent report by a
group of UK MPs called Philippe boxes to
be officially classified as gambling in
the UK which would make it illegal for
under 18 to purchase them . but for me
there's a greater issue at stake here we
can't allow the gaming industry on their
products to be reduced to a bunch of
push a button slot machines with fancy
graphics truly great video games are an
art form that when done with masterful
deft and care can invoke deep emotional
responses that will stay with you for
the rest of your life my fondest
memories in gaming are not opening
endlessly boxes to hope for a new
multicolored heart no my most treasured
memories were in games that were created
by developers who you can tell genuinely
care for the art form I remember the
first time I witnessed link playing his
ocarina of time I remember stepping out
of the cave in Skyrim to witness a
breathtakingly beautiful fantasy world
just begging to be explored I remember
listening to the local crackpot moaning
about her frying pan in the wits of free
and genuinely laughing out loud and of
course I remember beating a living [ __ ]
out of my first hooker in Grand Theft
Auto thanks for watching but no matter
what you like to do when you're gaming
you should be using nord VPN who have
kindly sponsored today's video I know
what you're thinking didn't note VPN
recently get hacked no not quite one of
their servers in Finland was breached
exposing it for a very short time
there's a big difference between a hack
and the breach I've personally spoken to
north VPN regarding this and I truly
believe that they are now hell-bent on
sharpening up their security to
unprecedented levels to ensure that
nothing similar ever happens again so if
you're considering a VPN solution then
that actually isn't a better time to
choose Nord VPN did you know that other
gamers can gain a competitive advantage
by launching DDoS attacks on your
internet slowing you down
but Nord VPN will protect you from such
an attack so you can game uninterrupted
Nord VPN works on any device Android iOS
Windows Mac Linux you name it I travel a
lot and I often do sensitive work on my
laptop banking messaging private
documents etc in coffee shops hotel
rooms and public spaces but I always use
naud VPN in these instances because it's
easy for hackers to intercept your
packets over public Wi-Fi and see
everything you're doing online nor VPN
do
encrypt your data so you can use any
Wi-Fi connection 4G or 5g and though
you're completely protected and your
data is secure click my unique link in
the video description to get 81% of a
free year plan for additional mumps Plus
naught pass for free thanks for watching
subscribe for a new video every week and
a big thank you to the sponsor Nord VPN
don't forget to check them out using the
link below